la conquête de mars la planète aux gets
à l'ag dote d'une demi-douzaine d'agents
spatiale mais avec le lancement réussi
de sa nouvelle mission persévérance la
nasa et met au premier rang la recherche
de vie extraterrestre se verront se
mettra sept mois pour atteindre son
objectif
un profond cratère mars y ait choisi
parce qu'à une époque très lointaine y
étaient remplis d'eau liquide est bordé
par une puissante rivière et s'il y
avait de l'eau on pourrait aussi
retrouver des formes de vie très
primitive est apparu sur la terre parce
qu'il y avait de l'énergie il y avait de
l'eau il y avait les bons composé
chimique
on croit que les mêmes ingrédients de
base étaient réunis sur mars pendant 1
milliards d'années et donc on espère
déceler des traces de bien ancienne
c'est au dernier modèle de rouvrir me
requinque on a confié cette tâche
extrêmement complexe l'appareil de la
taille de véhicules utilitaires possède
entre autres une vingtaine de caméras un
microphone un radar publiquement de
forage et d'analysé des sols
c'est un véritable laboratoire sur roues
un des objectifs scientifiques de la
mission de démontrer une capacité de
produire de l'oxygène donc lyonnais sont
à barr qui veut prendre co2 dans
l'atmosphère et transformé par procédé
électrochimique et produire de l'oxygène
pour la nasa investi deux milliards et
demi de dollars pour mettre au point
cette technologie raf unique qui compte
aussi nouveauté
le drone hélicoptère cet appareil de
kilos avec des pales de mettre 30 va
tenter le tour de force de voler dans
l'atmosphère martienne 100 fois moins
dense que celle de la terre
mais les américains ne font plus
cavalier seul au printemps 2021 la
chaîne devrait aussi avoir son propre
aux vins sur mars une mission sur
laquelle les chinois sont avares de
commentaires
oui il ya une forme de compétition je
crois que les chinois veulent établir
leur crédibilité dans l'exploration
spatiale démontrer que c'est une grande
nation bien produit qu'à terme il y aura
une collaboration véritablement
internationale mais tous les efforts
internationaux convergent vers un même
point préparer la future colonisation de
la planète et répondre à certaines
questions fondamentales à propos de mars
la question si la vie ailleurs est ce
que c'est une vie semblable à celle sur
terre est ce qu'il ya une une co
évolution ou c'est une forme de vie
complètement nouvelle qui était de
développer sur mars et et toutes ces
réponses pour être être intéressant pour
la science ici normand grondin radio
canada montréal